David: Good afternoon, everyone. My name is
David and this is Jez and we're
both engineers in the Sydney office who work
on the Maps API.
Jez: So we're talking today, our session's
called "Moving Beyond Markets:
Advanced Maps API Customization".
David: And just as with all the other sessions,
umm, there's a wave where you
can take notes, see notes being made live,
and also ask questions which we'll
try to answer at the end of the session. And
also I just wanted to mention that
all of the samples that we're showing today
will be available publicly at URLs
at the end. Don't worry about taking down
any code snippets or anything. It'll
all be there in the end.
Jez: Cool.
David: Great. Let's get going. So today we're
gonna be, umm, talking about
the JavaScript v3 API so this talk's basically
gonna be useful for you if you've
used the v2 API or the v3 API, or if you'd
like to learn some of the things you
can do with the JavaScript that's not too
high level.
Jez: Or if you're interested about cool new
things that we're going to announce
at the end of this session.
David:
>> [Laughing]
David: So, today. Today.
Jez: Today we're going to start with some
very basic customization, some things
that you can do -- you could do with the v2
API. We're gonna talk about custom
markers, customizing driving directions, custom
controls, some really simple
things you can do to make your Maps stand
out more.
David: Mm hmm.
Jez: Then we're gonna launch into some more
advanced stuff.
David: Right. So the first of the two things
we're gonna do is probably Jez's
favorite section and that's advanced Street
View customization. So really
innovative new things you can do in the v3
API such as bring in your own imagery
ask connecting it to existing imagery to get
a really immersive experience that
you could have never got before.
Jez: I think you're underselling our third
point there --
David:
>> [Laughing]
Jez: -- which I think is actually my favorite
thing. We're gonna be a bit
cagey about it but it's something new and
something that will allow you to take
Map customization to a new level. Really,
really brilliant stuff. It's
exciting.
David: Well, let's start at the beginning.
Jez: Okay.
David: So standard marker is standard. I mean,
we love the standard marker, we
love the standard look of Google Maps, but
a lot of the time when you're on an
API site that's all you see is just the standard
Google UI and having something
a little different that can really stick in
people's memory, make the site
really stand out or, you know, make the map
actually part of the web site
instead of this sort of stand alone thing
which isn't actually connected.
Jez: Exactly. So what are we going to do to
really make our Maps stand out in
terms of our markets? Well, you've got a case
study I believe.
David: I do have a case study. Umm, in my
spare time I've been working on a
bit of a community service web site called
"zombietrackersRus" and here we see
one of our standard sort of zombie web pages.
You can see them all congregating
around the mall. But the standard marker just
isn't working for me here.
Jez: Yeah. It's not really scaring me. I'm
not looking at these markers and
saying I should be freaking out and getting
away from the zombies or planning my
escape route from these markers 'cause the
markers are kind of nice. They're
kind of nice; right?
David: Kind of friendly. Ooh.
Jez: Now, that's looking better.
David: So you can see straight away you've
got a whole new experience.
Not only are you seeing visually straight
away what the marker represents but we can
do all
sorts of things like actually position the
markers to point at one another so
you can really see those zombies encroaching.
Jez: Encroaching? So you can even drag them
around.
David: Drag them around. They spin. It's that
simple.
Jez: Cool.
David: Great. So now -- so now I'm really,
like, aware of where the zombies
are and I won't, you know, freak out about
it.
Jez: I was actually working on a similar web
site.
David: Oh yeah?
Jez: Ninja tracker. Yeah.
>> [Clapping]
David: Nice.
>> [Laughing]
Jez: And you can to that with the Maps API
v3 as well, just like that.
David: All right. So we've got our custom
markers.
Jez: So how do we do that? What's the code?
David: It's -- actually, to get a simple marker
on the page it's really simple
to -- I just said "simple" twice then.
Jez: You do that a lot though, Dave. You're
a simple kinda guy, I think.
David: All you have to do is pass in the URL
of the image that you'd like to
use as the marker in the icon field of the
marker constructer and that's all you
need for a basic marker.
Jez: Cool. But we can do some better stuff
with the custom markers -- right?
David: Right. So in the case of the zombies
we actually used a giant sprite of
zombies who are all rotated in different directions
and in different lurching poses.
And so using the marker image, you can actually
take full advantage of that so
you get the performance of having sprites
but without much effort. So here you
want -- you just need to give things like
the size of the sprite you're using,
where on the sprite you are, and whereabouts
in that part of the sprite should
the marker be anchored onto the map.
Jez: Cool. And you can also scale it as well.
David: Right. And finally you can also take
a similar one of those marker
images and make a shadow, put them all together
with a custom click ranging
shape so that if you have a strange shaped
marker you can still get to the map
around it, and then if you pass those options
into the marker constructer you get
the -- the fully customized marker. But marker's
just really, like, the
simplest case.
Jez: It is. So let's go onto something a bit
more --
David: Advanced.
Jez: Yeah.
David: Custom directions.
Jez: Okay. So custom directions at the really
simple case looks a bit like
This, and if you're gonna show us exactly
how we can take this, which is pretty
much the sort of standard out-of-the-box thing
you get with directions in the API
and -- and make it a bit more interactive,
a bit more custom.
David: So this is my custom directions. It
doesn't look too much different but
there's actually a lot of stuff happening
here. I've used my own Polylines, I'm
using my own markers, and I've actually rendered
the left hand marker in my own
way, my own CSS.
Jez: Listened panel? That looks like it's
on the right to me, Dave.
David: I think you have to turn around, Jez.
I don't know. I don't know my
lefts and my rights. Umm, it's using -- I'm
using my own dom. The other thing
is, because I've made all the Polylines myself,
I can actually add my own
behavior to the map. So you see when I hover
over a region, it changes colorand also the
corresponding step is highlighted, and similarly
if I hover over a
step, then the Polyline is highlighted. So
just really little things like this
can change the behavior of your map significantly
and make it more memorable or
more interactive. And, again, not too difficult.
Umm, all we need to do is
instead of passing the directions response
to the standard directions renderer,
which will give you in two lines normal UI,
instead you pass it to your own
function in which you can go through the response
and actually read all the
information about it and draw the bits that
are relevant to you on the map. So
our response is made up of multiple routes
which have multiple legs and then each
leg has multiple steps. In the common case,
though, you're only having a single
rout and a single leg because you were just
asked for one set of directions
between two points. So you only have to worry
about rendering a set of steps.
So here you can see we're just taking the
first route and the first leg and in
every step, creating some list of elements
and adding them to our dom. So going
from here to, you know, a little bit more
complicated is iterative and quite
simple.
Jez: Cool. All right. Well, let's talk about
custom controls. Umm, custom
controls are really very easy to do. Umm,
so what we've got here is instead of
having the standard, umm, pan and zoom controls,
we've just put some arrows in
the corner of the screen which, umm, manipulate
the map like this -- really
simple example but we'll show you how easy
it is to do because in actual fact,
custom controls are nothing more than divs,
which just ineract with the map in the
JavaScript. So all we're doing is creating
a div element, styling it however we
like, and then all we're doing is when we
get a click on that element, we're
making the map do something cool. Is that
function actually in the API?
David: I'm not sure I've ever seen a map do
something cool before, Jez.
Jez: I've seen a map do lots of things cool,
actually but I don't think the
function's quite there. So if you guys wanna,
like, request that on the issue
tracker I'd like to see.
David: I'd star it up.
Jez: Yeah. I would, too.
David: All right. Umm, the only thing that
really sort of, uh, that you can do
intrinsically with controls is that you can
position them dynamically on the
map. So you can give one of these, uh, control
position constants and the map
will actually flow all of the controls intelligently
so that the -- we don't get
any overlap or anything like that. Because
it's well because they're just divs
you can also position them anywhere you want
absolutely anywhere on the map or
relative to the div.
Jez: Right. So that's actually one of the
things that's changed between v2 and
v3 -- whereas in v2 you always had to worry
about making sure that your control
wouldn't overlap one of the standard Google
controls that you'd added to the map
and so if they'd changed size you're in a
bit of trouble chasing it around the
map. With this, you just give the div to the
map and it'll look after making
sure everything fits nicely and nothing overflows
-- I mean, flows into each
other.
Jez: Mm hmm.
>> [Quiet]
David: Finally, umm, before we get into some
of the more advanced topics I'm
just gonna touch upon custom KML handling.
Now, think, often KML's a bit overlooked
in the API, but it really shouldn't be because
it's a powerful way to add a
lot of data onto your map, but also a good
way of separating the HTML and the
script, which is rendering the map from the
actual geographic data, so you can
have in one place a list of all the events
or a list of all your shops and in
another place, that's where you actually worry
about the presentation of it.
>> [Quiet]
David: So this is what a standard KML looks
like on the map.
Jez: Mm hmm.
David: I've rendered here just a list of all
the meteor impacts on the earth.
Jez: The what impacts?
David: Meteorite.
Jez: All right. I see what you said. Sorry.
I couldn't really understand
your Australian accent there, Dave.
David: And so it'll just draw a standard marker
for you. You can actually
change the image in the KML but you can't
change anything else. So when you
click, you get a standard info window with
the HTML content that was inside.
Jez: That was the description field; right
Dave?
David: That's the description field.
Jez: Cool.
David: So you can do a little bit but that's
about the limit of the
customization we can do.
Jez: So how can we make this better? How can
we make this our own?
David: If we take over the rendering of the
KML we still get it rendering the
markers for us so we get really high-performance
markers so we can add hundreds,
thousands of them to the map. But instead
of using the info window, we can
render it ourselves.
>> [Quiet]
David: So here, in the right hand panel, you
can see I've taken the same
Information, and I've rendered it myself,
and I've applied my own CSS so I don't
have to worry about different things on the
page interfering with it.
Jez: Great.
David: And the other thing --
Jez: As well as that. Yeah, you go -- this
is your slide?
David: This is my slide. The other thing is
we've actually been able to add
behavior as well to the KML. So I don't know
if you can see just around the
bottom of that marker there I've actually
drawn a circle about how large -- how
large a radius was made when it hit the ground,
how large the crater is. Is it
here?
Jez: We sort of emphasized it to make it obvious.
David: We widened it a little bit to make
it more obvious.
Jez: That would have taken out half of Africa.
David: But you can see --
Jez: It was a while ago, though.
David: You can see just with -- by taking
over KML I've actually changed the
experience quite substantially. And, again,
it didn't actually take much code
to get it done.
>> [Quiet]
David: So the first thing you wanna do is
when you make a KML layout -- sorry,
that should be google.maps.kml there. Umm,
is you're passing the suppress windows
option into the constructer and that just
says, hey, when you -- when someone
clicks, don't do anything for yourself. I'll
be here to help you out. The
second thing is then to add a listener for
that click event and when somebody
does click on the marker, not only do you
get the position at which the marker
was clicked but you get a whole heap of meta
information from the server about
what was actually in the KML. So in this case
the description field is actually
a full HTML body that I can add to the dom
or manipulate, and in our case we just
passed through the radius and added a circle
overlay to the map.
>> [Quiet]
Jez: Cool. So with all of the stuff we've
talked about so far, this -- you can
make your site look pretty sweet. Like, it
looks pretty good, you can customize
it, you can -- you can take the things that,
you know, make it look like Google
Maps and customize them so they can fit with
your site but I want to go a bit
further. So let's talk about some of the more
advanced things that we can do
with the API v3 now.
David: Sounds good. Okay. So we're gonna start
with Street View in v3. And
so we're gonna show a demo which shows how
you can actually put your own custom
panoramas into Street View and also link them
into the existing Street View
imagery. So we have here a map of the area
around the office, uh, the Google
Sydney office. We're going to go into Street
View and you can see here that
we've got a link here on Darling Island Road,
which is one of the roads that surrounds the
office into the Google Sydney office, and
we can also see we've got the logo
there which is a custom marker which is inside
the panorama object.
Jez: So I guess the first thing you notice
there is things like markers and
info window, you can actually take from your
map and bring along with you into,
umm, into your Street View really simply.
David: Absolutely. So let's go inside Google
Sydney. So this is the reception
and we can see links going off in different
directions towards the cafe and
towards, uh, the -- the area around -- near
us that we like to call the blue
room. So let's go through to the cafe. Beautiful
view of Sydney.
>> [Quiet]
David: Our well-stocked drinks fridge.
Jez: Ha ha.
>> [Quiet]
David: And so you can see that -- that this
is using just our own imagery that
we took -- Dave and I took one afternoon with
a camera and a tripod.
Jez: Last Friday, actually.
David: Last Friday it was. Yes?
Jez: Umm --
David: And we put it straight into Street
View and we integrated it with existing Street
View imagery.
Jez: So how do we do this? Let's start with
the simple things. To add
Street View to the map, it's really, really
easy. All you need to do is either
in the options for the constructer add Street
View controls true or set the
Street View control option to true, and then
you can get the panorama object by
just going map.getStreetView. So to add a
custom marker, because Street View in
v3 is entirely implemented in HTML, umm, and
you just interact with it with
JavaScript, and the other objects that you
can add to the map pretty much don't
care whether it's a map or a panorama. So
in this case the only thing we need
to do to get our custom marker on there is
change the map parameter for the
marker to the panorama.
David: Right.
David: And that'll put it in panorama for
us.
Jez: So you can do this with markers and info
windows, and your own overlays that
you create yourself and Polyline support is
on its way.
>> [Quiet]
David: Okay. So when you've got custom panoramas,
what you need to do is to
make sure that they wrap around 360 degrees
and then split them into tiles,
much as you would do if you were creating
a custom tile layout yourself. Umm,
so what we've got here is the tiles that make
up the imagery and they're square.
You can see they're square, and they've just
got a gray space at the top and
Bottom, and they're just indexed by the zoom,
the x coordinate, and the y
coordinate and the ID of the room that they're
currently in. Beautiful.
>> [Quiet]
Jez: So, uh, the next thing you need to do
is to set up the geometry, basically
the mapping of -- of where the rooms go, how
they link together. So what we've
got is the -- uh, this is linked from the
blue room, our origin hitting field
tells Street View which, uh, angle, which
heading the panorama starts at so when
you've got your 00 tile what that's heading
towards, and then just an array of
links which determine at -- where you can
go from this room and what heading it
should be on.
>> [Quiet]
David: As long as we've got that, we've got
this set pano provider function
which takes a function, when given a pano
ID, will, uh, return this object here --
determining the, uh, the stuff you need to
know to -- the stuff that the API
needs to know to render your pano. So the
important things are the location; the links,
which
are just the links that we saw in the last
slide; the size of the tiles; the
size of the world, which is the size of your
entire panorama so it knows how many, umm,
how many tiles there are around 360 degrees;
the origin heading which I spoke
about; and this function here called gettileURL,
which returns the URL of a
particular tile parameterized by the zoom;
and the x and the y.
Jez: Great.
David: And the last thing we have to talk
about is how to link it into existing Street
View. It's actually really simple. The panorama
object has links
changed event, and when that gets called we
actually, uh, get the pano ID, the
pano, for -- for the panorama. We get the
links for the existing panorama, and
we check the -- if this is the pano ID that
we care about. So in this case this
IUF one is the one on Darling Island Road
outside the Google office. We just
add our link to that, the link that goes into
Google Sydney and will send us to reception.
David: Great.
Jez: Cool. That -- it's that easy. It is.
Yes.
David: All right. So now we come to the last
exciting section.
Jez: Mm hmm. I'm looking forward to this.
I am.
David: So up to now we've customized what
we put on the map, and we've
customized Street View. What else, what left
can we possibly do, Jez?
Jez: Well, I was wondering because everything
we've done we've really kind of
focused on, you know, making this our own,
but there's one thing that we just
haven't been able to customize yet and that's
the map itself.
>> [Quiet]
David: You don't like the map?
Jez: I like the map --
David: I think it's a nice map.
Jez: I like the map. I do like the general
Google sign but sometimes I wish we
could modify it in some way.
David: Yeah?
Jez: Yeah.
David: Like what?
Jez: I don't know. Could -- could you perhaps
do something that would, like,
make it all desaturated a bit? Make the colors
less intense.
David: So, like, gray? Gray's good.
Jez: That's very interesting. So we can gray
scale the map; hey? I don't
want it just completely black and white. Can
we maybe bring it up a bit? Make
it a little bit more colorful.
David: Oh, you want it faded out.
Jez: Just fade it a little bit. Desaturate
it a little bit.
David: I think I can do that.
Jez: So compare that to what we had originally.
Let's have a look.
David: Oh yeah. I see what you're talking
about.
Jez: Okay. Cool. So we're desaturated a little
bit. What if I wanted to, like, change the
colors altogether in could I make it blue
for example?
David: Like that?
Jez: Ah. So now we're getting somewhere. Okay.
So we can change the hue of
the whole map.
David: But I'm not really happy with it, Jez.
Jez: Yeah?
David: I think it looks too cluttered.
Jez: Yeah. I was just thinking the same thing,
actually.
David: I was thinking maybe we should get
rid of some of the roads.
Jez: Some of the roads? Okay. How about get
rid of the local roads? Just the
really small ones. We'll keep focus on the
big ones. Ah, cool. So we can
actually now take out individual features
from the map. Is that what you're
telling me?
David: I think we can do more than that, Jez.
Jez: Great. 'Cause what I was really, really
wanting to do was -- I wanted a nighttime
map 'cause I'm a bit of a nighttime person.
David: A bit of a night owl?
Jez: Yeah, that's right. So can we invert
the lightness of the map?
David: I reckon we could.
Jez: Ah, cool.
David: It's a bit dark.
Jez: It's a bit dark.
David: It is a bit seedy almost. I don't know,
Jez. How's that?
Jez: That's looking better. I -- I do have
a problem, though, 'cause there's
parks up here but the parks are always the
same color to the water so you really
can't get -- can we make them stand -- I really
want the parks to stand out like
really, really much.
DeWitt: Oh. I'll set them to your favorite
color.
>> [Laughing]
David: What do you think, Jez?
Jez: Yeah. It looks good. I'm liking that.
I'm liking that a lot. I don't
know it might not be to everyone's taste.
David: If you add this to your web site it'll
be a bit --
Jez: How about we go back to a bit more traditional
color for parks.
David: Let's go to green.
Jez: Okay, great. So we can make the parks
green, everything else is blue,
it's nice and light. But the labels on the
parks are -- are green as well,
Dave. Can we just change the geometry of the
parks, not the labels?
David: Oh, you just want the geometry?
Jez: Just the geometry.
David: I think I can do that.
Jez: Okay. Great. All right. Cool. Uh, what
else do we wanna do?
David: Still a little cluttered.
Jez: Get rid of some of the extra labels that
we don't really need. All right. Cool. I like
this map.
So we've got -- so, what have we got here,
Dave?
David: Well, we've changed the color schemes,
we've changed the lightness,
we've changed the darkness, we've changed
what features are showing, what labels
are showing. We pretty much customized every
aspect of the map.
Jez: Cool. So now that we've got this -- this
styling available, there's a
whole -- a huge range of different things
we can do. So here's some styles you
can create now with this new feature called
map styling.
David: Nice API.
Jez: So here's a sepia toned map. We've got
some other themes we can do.
>>[Clapping]
>> [Quiet]
David: I like that one.
Jez: You like that one? You can even remove
things like completely remove all the
roads from the map. I use it to highlight
particular features so this one
highlights the transit routes around San Francisco
or even just remove
everything just to get the, uh, outlines of
the shoreline, like that.
>> [Quiet]
>> [Clapping]
David: Thank you.
David: That looks kind of difficult to do,
Jez.
Jez: You'd be surprised how easy this is to
do.
David: All right. Convince me.
Jez: So all you have to do is create these
style objects and there's three
elements to a style. There's the feature type
that you want to manipulate, and
we have a shallow hierarchy of features so
you can apply styles to, for example,
all of the roads on a map or just the local
roads or the arterial roads; the
element type, so that's the geometry or the
labels, that's what we did when we
were manipulating just the geometry of the
parks but we didn't wanna change the
color of the labels; and then a styles parameter,
which determines the
particular things that you want to do to the
element. So for example, uh, this
is reducing the saturation by 50 percent.
So let's have a look at some of the
other examples we can do. So this is taking
just the local roads and turning
the visibility off. And we can also apply
multiple styles to a particular
feature. So this is -- we're making the hue
of the parks green and we're
decreasing the lightness to make them a nice
robust dark green color. So these
are the stylers that you can apply. We got
a normal map up at the top and the
other elements that you can manipulate -- the
saturation, the gamma, the
lightness, the hue, and there's an invert
lightness property which will change
everything. As well as thatthere's also the
visibility, which will, uh, change
what? Visibility.
David: [Laughing]
David: Great.
Jez: And to activate a style, it couldn't
be easier. We have a new class called
a styled map type, and it just takes one of
those style objects, and then you just
simply add that styled map type to the map
and set the map type, and you'll have
your styled map. It's that easy.
David: So I think it's actually interesting
to see what you can do with this.
Like, it's all well and good to just -- just
make a new style, but how does it
come into practice? And we've got a great
example here from NBC.
Jez: So our partners at NBC local have this
thing, uh, called "moods" which
determines the, uh, particular mood that a
particular city has about a
particular story and these are all color coded.
So what they've done actually
is, is to take the color coding of the map
-- sorry, of the mood and then apply
it to a map of the area where the story is
-- is breaking.
David: So it's a really simple effect but
something that really would have
taken a lot of effort before.
Jez: It wouldn't have even been possible before,
Dave. I'm putting that out
there. I don't think it even would have been
possible before.
David: And now, a couple lines of code.
Jez: That's right. Cool. So, uh --
>> [Quiet]
David: We can go over to this one.
Jez: So we have a map style wizard available
that should be live --
David: Now.
Jez: About now.
David: You're looking at it.
Jez: You're looking at it now. Right -- where
you can play with all the things
so you can manipulate the different features
and apply different styles to them
and see how it comes out. And then once you've
done that you can get the, umm,
the JSON code which we'll -- which you can
just plunk in straight to your --
David: So for example if you wanted to --
Jez: I just realized I said "plunk". You were
gonna say "plunk" and you
didn't so I said plunk because you put it
in my head.
David: Plunk.
Jez: Plunk. Yeah.
David: Does everyone know what plunk means?
>> [Quiet]
Jez: Okay. Well, see.
David: You out-Aussied them, Jez.
Jez: I out-Aussied them.
David: He means replaced.
Jez: [Laughing]
Jez: Umm, this isn't just about advanced maps
customization. It's about Aussie
slang as well.
David: All right. So I guess if you wanted
a really quick demo, what would we
do?
Jez: What would we do? Oh, this is great.
David: Let's change the color of the water.
Jez: Let's change the color of the water.
David: All right.
Jez: What color? What color should we make
the water?
David: Red.
Jez: Red. Okay. Red. That's pretty easy. Ha
ha.
David: Hang on here. Any more requests?
Jez: Cool.
David: Feel free to shout anything out.
Male in audience: Saturated.
Jez: Saturated.
David: Yeah. Okay.
Jez: Do it, Dave. Make it bright red.
>> [Quiet]
Jez: And turn down the lightness a bit.
David: Turn down the lights.
Jez: There we go.
David: So you can see there's absolutely nothing
canned about the styles as you
change the JSON or as you set the JSON, the
style gets rendered for you
immediately.
Jez: Immediately.
David: It's pretty amazing.
Jez: Absolutely dynamic.
David: So this wizard is gonna be available
from the public docs and also from
the -- the code samples from today. So please,
take it and see what you can
create.
Jez: So this is -- this is, you know, a really
great new feature. It's a way
to really make the maps your own. So not only
now can you add your own custom
markers and custom controls and stuff but
you can take the, uh, the base map
itself and manipulate it and to make it really
fit in with your site or to do
some cool features like we saw with NBC.
David: Great. All right. Well, we're starting
to come to a close but before
we do, I'd just like to quickly give a plug
to the Google Developer Qualification,
which you probably heard a few times now at
a few of the sessions you've been to
but it's just a great way for -- as Geo developers
to be qualified and
recognized as engineers using the Maps API.
>> [Quiet]
Jez: So all the code from today's talk is
gonna be on
beyond-markers.appspot.com.
David: And if you have any questions we'd
love to answer them or feel free to
just send them on through the Wave.
>> [Quiet]
Jez: I'll switch over to the Wave now, in
fact.
>> [Quiet]
David: Yes. At the front.
Male audience member 1: So the demo that you
just showed just a moment ago is that actually
manipulating the pixels or is it requesting
new images when you change those --
and the reason I ask is, does that then rely
on HTML5 and the canvass object or
is that gonna work in older browsers?
David: Right. This is all done completely
service side so it's got support for
all browsers.
>> [Quiet]
Male audience member 2: Uh, how do you capture
the image, the static image of this one? I
think
right now Google Maps has this static maps
support.
David: Right.
Male audience member 2: And things like right
now I think I have problems with static maps
where if you have lots of notes and -- sorry,
if you have lots of markers and
these markers has custom icon. I think it
has a limitation on how much -- how
long the URL that you can send. Do you have
any way to resolve that?
David: Umm, at the moment there's no support,
like, once you've reached the end
of the URL that's it. I know that some of
the future things they might be
looking at is, say, KML support where you
can render KML directly onto static
maps, but at the moment really you've just
gotta work with --
Jez: It's one of the orientations of the web;
right?
David: Right.
Jez: We really did try, with static maps in
particular, we really did try to
make the -- the parameters as concise as possible.
But you still have to run
into a limit at some point.
David: Yeah.
Male audience member 2: Okay. Is it available
on Google Enterprise Premier as well?
David: Yeah. It's available to everyone.
>> [Quiet]
David: Hi.
Male audience member 3: Is there a roads attribute
that references cycling?
David: Good question.
Jez: Umm, I don't believe so, not at the moment
but that's -- we're -- we're
expanding the API. I think it's fair to say
that we're expanding the API for
maps styling so it's probably something that
we'll get to.
>> [Quiet]
Jez: Yes?
Male audience member 4: Uh, is there any performance
impact of styling the map and -- or,
like, picking colors with opacity or anything
like that?
Jez: Umm, intrinsically, no, there shouldn't
be any impact. The only impact
you're likely to see is users are less likely
to have a cached version of tiles
if they've used a different slide for example.
So, uh, if -- if you're using
the standard map tiles then they potentially
have been cached from visiting
Google.Com or from, uh, anything or any --
David: Any intermediate cache.
Jez: Exactly. Or any intermediate cache. So,
uh, potentially they might have to
fetch the new tiles.
Male audience member 4: So the regular style
is also render real time, it's not cache?
Jez: Yes.
>> [Quiet]
Audience: Okay.
Male audience member 5: Uh, for the styling,
will it be possible to, uh, limit it to a
region? Because, uh, we have a university
campus where the labels, they're not
really -- uh, the labels from Google we don't
like it and with what you showed
today we can just wipe those labels --
Jez: Right.
Male audience member 5: And replace them with
labels that they would prefer to see, but
it
will effect all the labels for the map on
the chosen university campus?
David: Yeah. At the moment everything's just
done on category rather than sort
of a geographical region. It's definitely
something we'd like to look at doing.
Like, if you think about the implications
you can do with that, there's thousands
of things, but at the moment we're just -- just
categories.
Male audience member 5: Okay.
>> [Quiet]
Male audience member 6: Can you bring in other
types of layers and mix and match? For
instance, if I just wanted the ocean to be
the terrain view -- or satellite view,and
I wanted the other parts to be maps, can you
splice those two together?
David: At the moment it's only actually supported
for the base map types so --
Male audience member 6: Yeah. OK. I was also
gonna second his notion on adding, geographical,
like,
separators and polygons. That'd be awesome.
David: No worries.
Jez: Add it to the issue tracker. Add a feature
request.
>> [Quiet]
Male audience member 7: Hi. Umm, sometimes
the maps is only the starting point. I may
use the
marker to get more information like in info
window or the rendering service
that you showed before. Umm, do you plan to
provide something else, I mean the
side bar, like in the Google Maps?
David: Umm, at the moment, no. It's -- umm,
we only fetch the information when
you click on it. So there's no, umm --
Male audience member 7: Like your rendering
services. I mean, it's hard to get something,
umm, really nice looking when you add a lot
of information in an info window.
So, umm, maybe you have some guidelines or
some ideas on how to show more
information that -- on the -- info window.
David: I would definitely, umm, steer away
from using the info window whenever
you had that sort of content to show. I don't
think we have any standardized
way of rendering that other than there's the
standard directions renderer for
the panel. Umm, yeah. I would -- you know,
it's really what you want your web
site to look like. So I wouldn't necessarily
make the panel any different to
the rest of your HTML content. Yeah.
Male audience member 7: Yeah. OK.
>> [Quiet]
Jez: Shall we take a question off the Wave?
David: Sure.
Jez: I'm getting, you know, really sort of
weird angles so I can hardly read
It on the thing.
David: Well -- a new question that just came
through. This all
excellent, thanks. Any chance we will be able
to change the font to more
customize the map or fit in with your branding?
>> [Quiet]
David: Not that we've heard of.
>> [Laughing]
David: Umm, I don't know. It could be on the
road map but I haven't heard
anything. Umm, I think that's probably a lot
more difficult to pull off but
you never know.
>> [Laughing]
David: Ask for stars.
Jez: Ask for stars. That's right.
David: Umm, have mouse events on encoded polygon
events improved for v3? I
believe -- well, is Ben here? No Ben. There's
been a lot -- or is there a Ben?
>> [Quiet]
David: Hey, Ben. Ah. I know, umm, Ben has
put a lot of work into changing the
way polygons are rendered on maps so I'm not
sure if he's actually had any
optimization on click-ability. Maybe you wanna
speak to that, Ben?
Ben: Hi, this is Ben. Can you please repeat
the question? Sorry.
David: Uh, sure. Umm, have there been any
improvements for mouse events on
encoded Polylines?
Ben: Yes. They're fast.
David: They're fast? There you go. So the
answer is, yes.
Ben: I'm happy to elaborate later.
David: Try v3 and if you find bugs, please
file them in the issue tracker
because that's the only way we're going to
be able to improve.
>> [Quiet]
David: Umm, the last one was, uh, the new
track element in KML that has been
introduced in Google Earth. Will Maps support
it? Oops. Sorry.
>> [Quiet]
David: Will we support tracking KML and/or
how can we draw custom paths on the
map?
>> [Quiet]
David: At the moment, umm, Track Web is supported
directly through the KML
Layout, but I can't see why it won't be supported
in the future. As to -- I'm
not aware of the API myself.
Jez: No, the KML.
David: Umm, come and chat with us later, and
we'll try and find someone who can
give you a more concrete answer. At the moment
I think the answer's no.
Jez: There's one more question, which I guess
might wrap it up if we don't get
any more.
David: All right.
>> [Quiet]
Jez: Will colorization API available for maps
for Flash? That's an interesting
question. Umm, uh, possibly. Maybe a -- that
may be a question for our product
manager. He's trying to hide in the corner.
Sorry? If there is sufficient demand. That's
a good product manager answer. That's right.
David: The answer is, star it up in the bug
tracker.
Jez: That's right.
David: And we'll find it.
Jez: All right. That's it from us. Thanks
very much.
David: If you have any questions, just grab
us.
>> [Applause]